U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinking
has held talks with Saudi Arabia's Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman ahead of a
meeting with Gulf Corporation Council
foreign ministers in Saudi Arabia the
U.S state Department says they had
candid discussions that included human
rights concerns and ending the war in
Yemen ties between Washington and Riyadh
have been strained in recent years to
discuss this further let's speak to
Hashem al-bar who's covered this region
extensively for Al Jazeera Hashem we saw
clearly in the body language here that
it's not warm ties
The American Secretary of State is
coming in a very different Saudi Arabia
than the US has been used to it's a very
different landscape where you have the
Saudis and Iranians reestablishing ties
in a deal brokered by China what can
they expect fully when you look at the
statement issued by the sound of the
news agency there's no specifics
whatsoever about what happened during
the meeting the Americans are returning
to a country which is completely
changing and they are trying to
understand whether there is a genuine
geopolitical shift in the country
particularly when it comes to
normalizing with
Iran building strong relations with
China and Russia or this is just part of
a political leverage by Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman to tell the
Americans in particular that when it
comes to this part of the world you have
to understand that you have to deal with
the most powerful country which is Saudi
Arabia and this explains why the
Americans are concerned because they're
just concerned that this could be the
beginning of a new era the end of
decades-long Alliance that was based on
oil in exchange for security can can the
Americans win back some of the influence
or have they completely lost ground to
China when you look up a development of
the ground it will take them some time
because the Americans say that they are
looking forward to see some uh and to
the conflict in Yemen you have two key
GCC countries on opposing ends of the
conflict the Saudis back the
international recognized government the
Emirates for example back the
secessionists the Americans need to
bring all those countries together to
try to negotiate a path but I think we
will have to wait and see what will be
the perception of the Saudis yeah and
and of course there's this GCC foreign
Minister's meeting in Saudi Arabia as
well and you've mentioned some of the
points of tension between some of these
GCC countries which we also saw when it
came to the question of of readmitting
Syria into the Arab League some
countries not completely on board with
that can they unite or are these
divisions too deep for the GCC to be
United you see and this is one of the
problems with with the US when it comes
to testing Waters in this part of the
world they say that the reason for this
meeting between blinken and the GCC
foreign ministers is basically uh to to
talk about security Regional issues and
also GCC integration but the GCC itself
is not a United block
we spoke earlier about the device
between the Saudis and the Americas
about Yemen
the qataris are not really in favor of
an overtures with the with with basala I
said of of Syria they have different uh
Visions about how to move forward and
also the GCC has been grappling with how
to get its act together and set aside
all those differences particularly
between the key players and the GCC Now
is it going to be easier for blinken to
tell the GCC countries for example you
know what we have to find a way to solve
the crisis in Yemen it's not going to be
easy at all because of the huge
differences between the Saudis and the
Emirates about Yemen Sudan say it's the
same thing so it's going to be a
delicate task ahead for the Americans
indeed uh it'll be interesting to see
what comes out of that meeting Hashem
thank you very much for that